بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
كرياض الصالحين الحافظ النووي رحمه الله
تعالى
ابي هريره رضي الله عنه
ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم قال يقول
الله تعالى
ما لعبدي المؤمن عندي جزاء اذا قبضت صفيه
من اهل الدنيا ثم احتسبه الا الجنه
رواه البخاري
الامام البخاري
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
الحديث القدسي
قدسي حديث
وهذا نسبه الى القداسه
والقداسه
والقدس والقدوس
والقدس
هو الطهاره
والنزاهه في لغه العرب
يقول الله تعالى ونحن نسبح بحمدك ونقدس لك
يعني ونقدس
نفوسنا وانفسنا لك او
و نسبح بحمدك وننزهك عما لا يليق بك وعما
نفيت عن نفسك ونقدس لك
وهو في الاصطلاح ما قال فيه النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم قال الله تعالى فهي روايه
عن الله
قدسي حديث
قدسي
القدس
والقدوس الله سبحانه وتعالى
القدوس
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الروح القدس ان
قران الله سبحانه وتعالى
جبريل عليه السلام الروح القدس
‏of
and this is one of the
description one of the names that is
used byer to
عليه السلام
and so
name
translates to the holy holy
‏Arab lang
spirit
and
as a حديثing
from a مرفوع
حديث
var types of
so you have
a statement of a compion
something compion says the scholars to
it
and then you refer to it
موقوف
موقوفي
المرفوع
صلى الله عليه وسلم
والقدس
قران
هذا هو التعريف المصطلح عليه بين العلماء
ان الحديث القدسي
ما يروي فيه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عن
الله
وليس من القران
ران
[Silence]
قي حديث
صلى الله عليه وسلم الله
ر
الله
andle
are الله عليه السلام
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم فالقران
هو قول الله لفظا ومعنا
واما الحديث القدسي
فهو قول الله معنى واللفظ فض من النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم فيوحي الله تعالى المعنى
الى الرسول
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يعبر
عن هذا المعنى بالفاظه هو يتخيرها صلى
الله عليه وسلم
قران
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
حديث
someish
them
way point here is
have when
say this is a me
proph
وىران
ابو هريره
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم الله
ما لعبدي المؤمن عندي جزاء اذا قبضت صفيه
من اهل الدنيا ثم احتسبه الا الجنه
الله ‏has said,
"My believing servant, my believing
slave
has no reward short of paradise
if I take from him his most beloved
from amongst his
relations
and he is patient and hopeful for the
reward.
‏He has no reward of parad for that.
What does this mean? This means that a
person every one of us every human being
has someone who is most beloved to them.
It's not necessarily a child. It's not
necessarily a parent. It's not even
necessarily a family member. Could be a
friend, could be someone
that is most beloved to an individual.
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله
[Silence]
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يكفر عنا سيئاتنا وان يتوب علينا نساله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يجعلنا من اصحاب اليمين
وان يصبرنا على البلاء وان يلهمنا الصبر
والسلوى والاحتساب
على كل ما نبتلى به في هذه الدار والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين